the earth wit school in Hackney East
London is on the up founded in 15-20 to
educate the poor after a checkered past
results that are improving and pupils
are disciplined but there is real fear
here about changes to the funding
formula designed to redistribute money
more fairly between inner-city schools
and those in parts of England that have
historically received less the
government has promised that no school
will lose cash but head teacher Richard
Brown is worried about a race to the
bottom and the uncertainty around to
resumes fragile new government isn't
helping either I don't know my budget
for the next financial year which will
start next April I could be looking at a
3% cut I could be looking at a budget
that is similar to what I've got now I
can't do any long term financial
planning while there is this continual
uncertainty that stems from government
so just to be clear if your fun things
can't that means you'll have to get rid
of teachers if our funding is going to
be cut year-on-year for the next three
years which is something that was
suggested 3% a year for three years
there is only one way of then living
within that cut and that is by making
teaching staff redundant now we have a
dedicated set of teachers here
experienced teachers who meet the needs
of the children and yet I might have to
be in a position of deciding if any of
those need to go that is not where I
want to be it's not where parents want
me to be and it shouldn't be what
government wants either and how many
teachers are you talking about
worst-case scenario if we were facing 3%
cuts for the next three years which is
something that was proposed at one point
that could be anything up to 25 teaching
posts and that would be a catastrophic
situation for us to be in and equally
it's not just this school every school
in Hackney and every school in in London
is facing exactly the same situation do
you think politicians really understand
the pressures that schools are under no
I think that they imagine that there's
some sort of fat and that we can trim
the fat and then we can still deliver
what we're delivering now that is not
what we can do we have already reduced
the number of support staff in the
school
we're spending less money on music
tuition next year so far we have avoided
any staff redundancies we've used
natural wastage other schools in the
area have already made teachers
redundant this is a real issue for
schools that politicians do need to
address urgently pay is another
contentious issue since 2010 public
sector pay rises have been frozen or
capped at 1 percent teachers here worry
it's putting people off the profession
being newly married it's a strain you
know to buy a property and that's
something I want to be able to do in the
future but it you know with cuts you
know to my pay there's only so much I
can do so currently I am renting but I'm
hoping that in the future that's
something that can obviously change so I
can buy my own puppy and be a homeowner
and could it be putting off other
teachers entering the profession
yes definitely during my teacher
training I was studying to be a teacher
with many passionate individuals who are
currently now leaving the profession
because of the pay cuts we love the
profession so we're here I think new
people going through university thinking
about doing PGCE they're probably put
off because they're thinking am I going
to be able to afford to live now things
are getting political with parents
producing slick campaign material and
even roping in the kids to this
particular sing-along was produced by
fair funding for all schools who are
march on Westminster next weekend
calling for increased investment in
education parents are very concerned but
also very unhappy because we've been
lied to the last government said that
education spending was protected but it
wasn't and this means that parents are
deeply unhappy that that their children
will be impacted by these cuts when they
needn't be we should be investing in our
schools after losing her majority Teresa
may is vulnerable and MPs have centered
blood
she's already ditched plans to scrap
free school meals for primary schools
now politicians from all parties are
calling for an end to the public sector
pay cap
the problem is all this costs money how
much you can do about public sector pay
is about as long as a piece of string
each 1% you add to the public sector pay
bill cost you more than one and a half
billion pounds so each little bit costs
quite a lot so if you want to do a lot
then it's gonna cost you a really
significant amount I'm keen to talk a
bit more widely about austerity as well
because it seems like it's become a bit
of a dirty word recently is it if you
look at social care you look at the
health service you look at what's
happening in prisons to some extent you
look what's happening in schools and
you're really beginning to see that
there is an impact in terms of the
quality of public services in terms of
waiting times and all those sorts of
things so it's got much more difficult
in the last couple of years so it's now
the time to ease up fun on austerity
there is a there is potential scope to
ease up on austerity we could spend an
extra few billion pounds a year but in
the end you know we have debt still at
ninety percent or nearly ninety percent
of national income at some point we
really need to make a choice and that is
are we going to have a bigger state if
we're gonna have a bigger state more
spending in total then at some point we
will have to have more tax or we're
going to decide well we the state at its
current level is about the right size in
that case we just have to get used to
living in a world in which we've got
less in the way of public services then
we would previously have expected in
extreme times however political
expediency often Trump's fiscal rules
it's not just backbench MP is arguing
for a public sector pay rise but
ministers - as a result the austerity
agenda may not survive the end of the
year no matter how much it costs